now we're now joined by counselor to the
president Kelly Conway Kelly Anne I want
to first play for you some of the
challenges we saw down at the border
last week let's watch we have to remove
from the field patrols to fill bottles
and the good thing is many of us are
parents so we know how to change diapers
and we know how to feed bottles Tenace
somebody goes I think Washington goes on
YouTube figures out how to cross because
he gets picked up by the Border Patrol
then released within 24 hours so Kelly
Ann after seeing this I my instinct is
to say why not deal and focus all of the
administration's rhetoric on that that's
Dan's right it is a raging fire at the
border right and a fire of humanity
endangering themselves in our country
and yet we're talking about legal
immigration I'm not I'm not getting that
yeah well there's two points to the
president's big proposal today Laura and
one is full and final border security
which he's been talking about for the
four years he's been running for him
being president the second part is the
modernization and merit-based
immigration system you at least went
down to the border the president's plan
today does the same thing he's talking
to the professionals at the border what
do they need he's not bothering with the
people behind you in Congress because
they failed to act they can just fix
Flores they can fix T V PRA so that we
as or as the court decisions that
compels us to release kids after 20 days
we have no we have no opportunity other
than to do that they can fix that the
people right behind you can do it but
they fail to act so the president's
taking on but this is full and final
board border security first we will have
1 million people coming to this country
now this year illegally and I think when
some people here are catching release
they may not be aware of the catching
beasts means release into the interior
not released back to their home country
they hear that I think well that's a
good idea
for years the flow was single males from
Mexico they could be returned to the
home country
to do that now with the flow of children
and adults but what's the purpose of
this plan I mean I think there's a lot
of good stuff two big things one is
what's the final and flat legislation it
would be if we could even get the
Democrats to read the plan and come and
talk to us about it
but this president wants full and final
border security it means you close all
the loopholes at the border you give
these border secured agents what they've
been asking for which includes more
technology the barrier of the wall we're
going to have about 400 miles of it done
soon even the newspapers are starting to
say that it caught my eye that the
Washington Post ABC poll reported that
there's 17% increase among Democrats
from January when Chuck and Nancy said
manufactured crises to April they're
calling it a crisis now they've seen the
pictures but border security means
exactly that it means closing the
loopholes having that barrier said that
Congress is not going to do it let me
talk about Blumenthal Blumenthal the
Richard Blumenthal from my home state
honestly but he says it sees this
despicable demagoguery so how so you put
this out there so my question is is this
really a 2020 platform for all
Republicans that's ironic that's not we
would love for them to come to the White
House tomorrow and find a way to act on
this at least read it that is dismissive
demagoguery by Blumenthal it doesn't
even matter if he's not going to read it
and consider it but this is not a 2020
document if the Congress can act now
we're interested in 2019 so in addition
to full border security it also does
modernizes a system that has not been
touched since 1965 fifty-four years so
members of Congress certainly are never
term lumina but fresh and creative ideas
for immigration were term loaded along I
think it makes sense of just endless
family members coming as quo so this
focus on the immediate family not just
you know adding to you can you could
still sponsor a minor children's parents
and that was why is he verified not and
a lot of us were really hoped with the
president has talked about a verifier so
often Stephen Miller is a big fan of
e-verify if you stopped the employment
for these people they won't come most of
them are just economic migrants the two
big fronts that we felt comfortable
putting forward now because the
President sees the
urgency and the ice urgency of border
security and also we want to shine a
light on the fact that nobody in
Congress has bothered to touch the legal
immigration system in 54 years why is
that because so many of them are vested
in the status quo they pretend they're
worried about the children they pretend
they're worried about the families if
they were they wouldn't be happy they
would do something about girls out the
ages of our daughters being pumped up
with birth control on their way on the
treacherous journey and then tested for
pregnancy when they get here some
outrageous it's they don't know what
happens to those kids once they get here
and they're released and they were the
kids were traumatized they are they
they've come all the way on that journey
with no guarantee they've been lied to
by the Coyotes who take their life
savings and worse for many of them so
the Democrats I think they want this as
a 20/20 issue we like to resolve it in
2019 was there any thought of reducing
the legal immigration numbers 1.1
million a president ran in part on maybe
re-examining that Stephen Miller was
always for lowering immigration until we
get the border solved maybe pause it I
mean people even said pausing
immigration except for extreme cases
reframing here it's merit-based which
means that in this country 12% of our
illegal immigration comes from
employability 66 or so percent comes
from basically a loser this flips it
Canada already has it flipped New
Zealand has it flipped so we're looking
at a system that's more aligned with
those other countries who yes welcome
immigrants as we do also Laura this
ridiculous raise the wage artificially
or get minimum wage raised artificially
our wages are now 22 dollars an hour we
have 7.5 million in don't let them solve
the country with more people that allow
it start lowering wages that's what I'm
here legally and get one of these 7.5
million jobs
Kellyanne Conway thanks for staying up
late tonight we really appreciate it